- So somebody told me this crazy story.
Did you, 'cause polar bears
are, well the most vicious,
and I heard that you literally, maybe had
some alcohol one time-
- Oh gosh.
- And were running on a beach
where a polar bear was eating.
- I was in a-
- It feels like a bad idea.
- It was a terrible idea.
It was in a movie with Barry Pepper.
I love, you know, Barry
Pepper, Great Canadian actor.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- And it was up in, like,
Churchill, Manitoba, I think.
And we were drinking at
the wrap party, I think.
God, help me, I think.
- All of this says, I think.
- I think.
And then I think in the moment
we're like, "You know what we should do?
"We should, like, race down the beach."
And so me and him and another guy came,
we came running down this beach
and a guy that lived there
just started swearing.
Literally swearing at
us and just screaming.
I mean screaming bloody murder.
- Buzzkill.
- Yeah.
But 'cause we didn't
realize we were running
to our certain death
(audience laughing)
because there were polar
bears all down the beach.
And yes, they're the most aggressive.
God, but they're so cuddly.
- They're beautiful.
(audience laughing) Yeah.
- Yeah, but they will eat you.
- In those Coca-Cola commercials-
- Yes.
- You're like snuggle, yeah.
- And so that is true, I did that.
Like, sometimes I wonder about that,
how close I was to being, like,
a little polar bear lunch.
- Yeah, well who would've thought
they were just polar bears?
Nobody ever hears that,
"Oh, there's polar bears
hanging on the beach."
It just doesn't happen.
- Well, yeah, up there was amazing.
We used to rent these little zodiacs.
- Yeah.
- Oh my god, why can't
I remember his name?
He's such a beautiful human
being: James Cromwell.
- Yeah.
- Remember James Cromwell?
He's such a wonderful character actor.
You might remember him from "Babe",
remember, "That'll do pig."
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah
- [Audience] Yeah.
- And he and I used to go and, yes.
(Michael, Kelly and audience applauding)
- Give it up, give it up.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm trying to know,
are we clapping for James or the pig?
- The pig.
"That'll do."
- Or just that I remember,
"That'll do pig"?
- All of the things,
we're just happy in the new year.
(Kelly chuckling)
- But we used to, it was like 40 bucks
and we would go and
rent a zodiac and go out
and all these little beluga
whales would follow us,
Good times.
- [Audience] Aw!
- Oh, that's beautiful, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- You know, let's move on.
- No, that's beautiful.
It's important for me
to get out of the city
and experience stuff like that
for my, like, emotional state.
- Oh, it's so cool.
Everyone in your audience,
almost everyone, literally at
the same time just went, "Aw"-
- Yeah.
- Except one dude,
right there.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- Calling you out.
- That was you,
in the beautiful gray: good looking dude.
And he did this, like this.
- [Kelly] He's like, that
sounds horrible, man.